[Music]
welcome to today's developer update I'm
Jeff from the overwatch team this is a
very exciting one because on May 23rd
2016 we launched overwatch and we really
didn't know what the reception was going
to be like and it was absolutely amazing
and we are so fortunate here at Blizzard
that so many of you came along for the
ride and not only played overwatch but
fell in love with it like we fell in
love with it and you guys really made
this game your own and now this universe
belongs to you so in order to celebrate
the anniversary of overwatch we will be
having our overwatch anniversary event I
think there's going to be a lot of cool
stuff for many of you for different
reasons first off there's going to be an
anniversary specific loot box that has
some of the most amazing items we've
made to date for example hanzo mains
have been asking us for new Hanzo
legendary skins and there's a really
great one in here we hope you enjoy it
same with Zarya mains we've heard a lot
of talk about wanting a new Zarya skin
and it's in there for you there's also a
great lucio skin and we're doing some
very special experiments with that one
to see if we can try new things we were
putting two new songs on the lucio skin
that adapt put the healing song and the
speed song to the style of the skin
which is sort of in this jazz style so
we really hope you guys enjoy some of
the skins we've made extra special in
this anniversary loot box our dances for
all of the heroes our animators had a
ton of fun exploring each of our
characters and asking themselves you
know how would soldier 76 dance if you
went to a party and you saw Reaper what
would he be doing in his dance
what would Reinhart stance be we hope
you have fun unlocking these and
checking these out and playing with them
in game we look forward to sort of the
funny moments that we expect to come out
of that so lots of cool loot box items
from the anniversary loot boxes
more than I'm going to mention in this
dev update but there's also cool
permanent content coming as part of this
anniversary event and we wanted to talk
about some of that with you as well
so for the arcade we will be adding
three new arena maps to the game arena
Maps if you guys remember are things
like eco point Antarctica which are
smaller Maps that we can do some
different modes on that enable you know
really fun and different gameplay types
so let's talk about some of the the maps
and modes that we're going to add we are
going to add a black forest map that
takes place between the Black Forest
outside of icon walled and I can wall
castle itself so sort of between where
the last bastion the movie took place
and the Battle of icon walls so there's
a really cool black forest map that
features a very unique design to it you
can shortcut to the enemy spawn almost
instantaneously in this map if you want
to so immediate clash of action we're
also adding a map called necropolis that
takes place outside of the temple of
Anubis and takes place at night
this map is a lot of fun because there's
some special story elements here you can
see an area where Jack Morrison is
hanging out waiting to gain information
from on Omari and on a Amore's workshop
and hideout is in this location as well
so we hope you have fun with that
there's also a really cool pit in the
middle with some interesting jumps that
you can do both across the pit and down
into the pit and still live so we hope
you enjoy the necropolis map as well
lastly we'll be adding a map known as
Castillo Castillo is a fort that looks
out over Dorado in fact you can look
down and actually see the entire Dorado
layout down beneath you takes place on
the beautiful Mexican coast and it
features a really cool round design to
it which encourages almost immediate
action but a really cool circular flow
to it as well
think you'll find it a lot of fun you'll
also see some cool story hints in here
you'll see sombras hacking den and you
will see the bar in which McCree and
Sombra were in the reflections comics so
both of those things are things to look
out for there's also a cool little
somewhere toast out lay off to the side
so three new maps coming these maps not
only will be added for the anniversary
event but will persist them be a part of
overwatch from now on and you can access
them not only in the arcade modes that
I'm about to talk about but in custom
game as well so that brings our total
arena map number up to four so these new
modes first of all let's talk about
elimination we're going to change how
overtime works in elimination or I
should say sudden-death so the way it
used to work is after a set amount of
time you would get a warning and then it
would reveal both characters but we
found there was a lot of frustrating
moments in particular with characters
like road hog or soldier 76 with their
self-healing who could sort of avoid the
enemy as much as they wanted to and
force a draw to happen we're changing
this dynamic completely what will happen
now is after a set amount of time we
will give you a 30-second warning at the
end of those 30 seconds a capture point
becomes available usually in the center
of these arena maps and once that point
is available whoever captures it wins so
that means the days of Symetra and eco
point antarctica camping out in her
spawn room the whole time waiting for
the enemy to come and if the enemy
doesn't come for a draw
those days will be gone you now need to
go out and fight and if you don't go out
and fight that capture point is going to
end the match very quickly in our
internal playtesting it's playing really
well we'll watch how you guys play it
and we'll do some tunes tuning and
tweaking and adjusting when we see you
know just how long should it take and
are we revealing it soon enough but
beyond the tiebreaking mechanism which
we're excited about we're adding two new
ways to play elimination and in the
custom game options you can set these to
any player amounts you want but in the
arcade
good for anniversary first of all we'll
have something called limited duel and
what limited duel is is each round when
it's a 1v1 mode and each round when it
starts we will give you and your
opponent a random three set of heroes
but you guys have the exact same three
heroes to pick from and you can pick any
hero you want and what this does is
create a lot of fun sort of play and
counter play what you're trying to do is
figure out you know not only what hero
are you best at but what hero stands the
best chance against the other two heroes
that got selected so there's some really
interesting rock-paper-scissor type of
decisions in the limited duel mode and
this mode again will be available in
custom game and you could try it with
you know more than just one player if
you want we really look forward to
seeing what you guys have to say about
that the other thing that we're adding
is a lockout elimination and the way
lockout elimination works first of all
for the anniversary event we're setting
it to three players and the way that
this works is both teams select whatever
three heroes they want kind of like how
elimination works today but as soon as
your team wins with those three heroes
they are locked out and you're not
allowed to play them again so if your
team picks Roadhog soldier 76 and honor
as your composition and you win the very
first round of that elimination mode
well you're not allowed to play Roadhog
soldier 76 and on again they're now
locked out for you this came about as a
community suggestion we thought it was
fantastic
we've been play testing it a lot and we
really enjoy it so we hope you enjoy it
as well
again all of these options will have
extra ability for you to tune and tweak
them as you like in custom game and we
highly recommend you start playing
around with these new maps and mode in
custom game so that's just the tip of
the iceburg some of the fun stuff that's
coming as part of the anniversary event
really we want this event to be a
celebration of you our fantastic
community
we would not be where we are today
without you this game absolutely belongs
to you guys I consider us just the
custodians of overwatch at this point it
is your world you are the heroes you're
telling us what's going on we cannot
thank you guys enough for what an
amazing year it's been and we look
forward to the year in front of us thank
you
[Music]
you
you